it is sort of a new era for hatred mail
the era of Trump and we've seen the even
further debasement of the hate mail that
is coming in regularly it's scary in
many ways it leads to more contacts with
law enforcement that's for sure if you
don't know what I'm talking about what
is hatred mail this is hatred mail
we're so all right it's wrong patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom yes so it was Veterans Day this
week and we have a hatred mail here I
guess in that theme from someone
claiming to be a veteran although can we
really believe anything that Patriots
say I don't know let's take a listen to
it together see if we can make heads or
tails out of it look [ __ ] Pakman if you
served this country as I have went
overseas and saw what these this
so-called devout Muslim bastards did to
our servicemen you would be anti-muslim
too so [ __ ] off
bleeding hard NPC betta cook male loser
you keep getting better-looking and more
intelligence every day give me a break
who say who saying that I that's not
he's arguing against praise that I've
not actually heard made of me but what
you might notice there is that there's a
big focus on masculinity and today's
voicemail later on in the show actually
addresses that exact issue issue so I'm
gonna come back to that for now I'll
just remind you that you can send a
message of a middle finger to the
hatreds by making a new membership at
WWN pakman.com with the coupon code hate
3:40 every time you use the coupon code
hatred forty two hundred ninety seven
hatreds cry you get a membership at
forty percent off and independent
progressive media wins h atri ot is the
coupon code use it unlimited uses are
available right now